this is a picture is a moment Frozen in
Time
and as these moments unfold at this
year's World Cup
Carlene Jackson has been painting them
on murals across the city
like this one on doha's Cornish
depicting one of the best goals by a
certain Brazilian with Charleston
Carling is one of the most commissioned
sport artists in the world
I started playing football when I was
four in Canada and my dream was to play
in the World Cup as is every young
footballer's dream and so when that
dream was dashed Away by injury the
ability to come here as an artist now is
transformational like I don't have I
don't really have the words it's having
the knowledge of being a former athlete
I'm able to understand the moments these
athletes want painted the passion the
sense of immortality the emotion on the
field and and to accurately paint
something you have to experience the
emotion and then translate it into paint
on the canvas foreign
she works exclusively for professional
athletes having been one herself she
calls them portraits of immortality
capturing moments like this 1970s shot
of Pele and Bobby Moore
that and several others were taken by
John Barley of the Daily Mirror of
London his grandson James Varley is
working on the World Cup in Qatar and
has teamed up with Carling to exhibit
these images at the next World Cup in
2026.
what we want to do in 2026 is Showcase
these photographs to fans of the next
World Cup in Canada Mexico and the
United States and we can show these
iconic these retro these Incredible
World Cup images at all different cities
across 2026 and hope to really like tell
the story of football and get people
excited about the next World Cup
nowadays a click can capture a single
moment but not all of Qatar 2022's
defining moments are captured on camera
some are captured in public murals and
sketched into World Cup history
in a career of memorable moments will
Messi provide one more
[Music]
fungien Al Jazeera Doha